les hier encore c'était de la science
fiction une équation mathématique dans
l'esprit du grand einstein l'objet de
nombreux romans et de films
mais aujourd'hui c'est une réalité
scientifique saisie
voici la première image d'un phénomène
physique qui dépasse l'entendement
un trou noir et pas n'importe lequel un
trou noir supermassif située à 55
millions d'années lumière de la terre
avec une masse équivalente à 6 milliards
de soleils
moi je t'appelle les monstres dans
l'univers c'est vraiment les objets les
plus puissants à lui seul un trou noir
supermassif complètement détruire une
galaxie c'est ça sa puissance c'est
vraiment incroyable
en plus de courbes et l'espace temps
comme l'avait prédit einstein litres ou
noah aval littéralement la lumière ce
qui les rendait jusqu'ici impossible à
observer ce qu'on voit vraiment dans
l'image cette surface noire
ça représente justement la zone dans
laquelle rien peut s'échapper même la
lumière c'est pour ça qu'on voit rien
c'est noir la lumière s'échappa mais
autour du trou noir
il va avoir de la matière ce que la
photo montre cette couronne de lumière
c'est la banlieue du trou noir
là où la matière et les gaz
incandescents tourbillonne une dernière
fois avant d'être engloutie par le
monstre les sciences in time before des
images des images pour réaliser cette
seule photo il a fallu deux ans de
travail des chercheurs de 40 pays v
télescope dispersé du pô sud jusqu'à
l'hémisphère nord une quantité
astronomique de données c'est un défi de
technologiste un défi de collaboration
c'est un défi danalyse à quantité de
données et est immense à sommes chacun
radiotélescope accumulait l'équivalent
de 5 100 téraoctets de données
ce gigantesque instrument virtuel de la
taille de la terre va continuer
d'étudier les trous noirs dont qui se
trouve au centre de notre propre galaxie
depuis les observations en avril 2010
est la collaboration à augmenter et donc
de nouveaux radio télescope qui se
joignent à ce super télescope virtuel et
donc à terme c'est une nouvelle ère pour
ce domaine bien précis de 2 des cas
extrêmes de la gravité ici non membres
ondes radio canada montréal